so I got a ton of tweets over the
weekend that we're asking me hey David
are you going to be at the straight
Pride Parade in Boston this weekend it's
happening you should be there you should
interview people you should counter
protest or whatever because you live in
Boston anyway and no I didn't go for
safety reasons because I didn't want to
give it any attention I ended up
actually being out of the city anyway as
I often am both during the weekend and
after the during the weekend but this is
not an event that appealed to me the
event happened there were straight Pride
Parade errs there were counter
protesters actually more counter
protesters than paraders there was a
massive police presence my contacts in
law enforcement and the Intel community
told me that they were really busy
managing all of the different threats
and extremist groups that were expected
to come in there were more people
protesting the parade than people
marching for straight pride in total
there were about 35 verse 36 arrests in
total I don't know what percentage of
those arrests were marchers versus
counter protesters I'm guessing at some
point soon we will have that information
the marchers definitely had some themes
in their messages support our troops was
a theme build the wall was a theme great
to be straight is a theme a lot of pro
Trump stuff just make America great
again and this type of thing some people
were hurt nine people ended up at area
hospitals so people here already know my
feelings about this type of parade in
general a straight Pride Parade is
unnecessary in the sense that it's not
just if you have a Gay Pride Parade then
obviously everything's fine and you
should have a straight Pride Parade the
idea behind a gay pride parade is that
we are talking about it historically
marginalized and discriminated against
group whose place in society
good people want to affirm most people
are straight people don't get fired for
being straight straight people have
always been able to get married to those
to whom they are attracted I don't even
want to dignify that part any further
the idea of you know a white pride group
a white student union or
whatever as the same thing as a Latino
Student Union well you're not talking
about a historically marginalized and
oppressed group and we have to really
examine what the motivations are of a
lot of those groups and the motivations
aren't good okay so that that's where
we're going to stop with that analysis
because it's such a stupid analysis that
it doesn't even need to be done one
reason I didn't go is I don't want to
give them attention
I think counter protesting is totally
valid but they aren't really marching
for straight pride they are marching to
anger people they are marching to
trigger and own the libs as they like to
say and some of them are marching
because they genuinely struggle with
their masculinity but that's a whole
other story
which we're not going to talk about
today very few of them actually show up
to this stuff to really protest and
again there were more counter protesters
this time around what would happen if
nobody showed up to counter protest and
however many people I don't even know
how many marchers there were was it a
few dozen was it a hundred people a
couple I don't know imagine if no one
gave them any attention they show up
they march around with their maggots and
their build the wall signs and they're
totally ignored no one protests no one
cares no one tries to fight the permit
for the parade they are just ignored no
one writes about it they are irrelevant
I think that that actually is a really
great scenario now again I was out of
town anyway and there were all sorts of
security concerns in terms of some of
the extremist groups that were coming in
but these are just small groups of
people doing really dumb things what if
we did just ignore them now other
perspectives are valid it when when
Bernie Sanders chose to do a FoxNews
Town Hall the idea being I'm gonna go
right in there and talk directly to
people who might be on the right and
maybe I can convince them and Elizabeth
Warren said I'm not going to participate
at all because I don't want to dignify
in some sense hate for-profit Fox News
and give them ratings both of those
perspectives are valid I respect what
Elizabeth Warren did and I think Bernie
Sanders crushed it in his debate but
both are valid approaches in the same
way you can take the perspective that a
large showing of peace and love by
counter protesters
the straight Pride Parade is the best
way to fight against the message of the
straight Pride Parade that's fine I
opted for a different path and I wonder
if every time they tried to organize one
of these they just get the permit and
nobody cares people go and do other
things they go to the music great
museums in Boston they go to all of the
different great things that there are to
do in Boston and they just don't give
any attention to these people would they
keep doing these parades something tells
me that they probably would not they
would not be doing this if no one paid
attention because the whole point of it
is to get attention so I didn't go I
wasn't there I was out of the city in
any case but I would not have gone if I
was in town to be totally honest with
you